and we're live with audio this time I'm
Eric that's Miguel we're checking out
gear club unlimited on the Nintendo
switch one of the first actual like
racing car games on the switch and we'll
pretend like all that stuff that just
happened didn't happen
Miguel nothing none of that happened I'm
surprised as I can't think of an earlier
release of a racing game on on the
switch yeah that's like I couldn't think
of one either so I'm pretty sure that's
accurate this as you had mentioned as
you had mentioned when you were muted
feels kind of like a mobile port and
that's not too shocking just in the
sense that there was a gear Club on like
Android so you know now it's on the
switch how are you are you enjoying it
or you know what do you what are your
first impressions I know you've only
done a couple rolls I mean I've won
every race handily I didn't realize that
they start you off at the novice
difficulty a lot of the assists on bail
or this before this race I adjusted
somebody assists I'm not playing totally
at sim level controls but I'm trying to
give the AI a chance I'm curious if any
viewers did play the gear club game on
mobile because I know nothing about it
but so far the one thing that's really
stuck out to me is just like how large
the map is I'm sure the the mobile game
was almost as feature-rich as this game
is it's like 400 cars in this game
really yeah I'm sorry not 400 cars 400
challenging races I'm a I'm a big boy
toy okay but yeah do you know many cars
apparently you can have four players on
the same screen though right which
that's the only version of let's go
normal I don't know I already said it
yeah I actually set it to normal before
before this stream okay
this guy's name is Joe all right Joe you
can change the graphic assistances you
receive it anytime and puzzle menu so
experiment seek to Mario Kart that is
kind of true any year raposo Rubio the
cost of this game is 44 and 99 so you
could play this today if you want it is
out if you're looking for kind of like a
logo and say it like one like our katie
racer well it's pretty Arcadia the first
the first sort of like well-known series
that called to mind as I was exploring
this game was test drive unlimited okay
yeah funny that when if they thought the
same thing adding that unlimited yeah oh
yeah this is pretty forgiving compared
to the last time we did some racing two
laps
I'm always about the whole running into
people and it's okay Roy is like in Gran
Turismo or like porta it's probably
frowned upon so right I'm worn - they
are kt racers yeah
I haven't seen many incentives to sort
of play fair though yeah that that
pulsating rewind button is to remind you
that hey if you messed up you can rewind
if you like had any recent
the second-place persons only 40 meters
behind me seems to be a large yeah yeah
I mean even with that slight little
crash maybe we should try an expert in a
little bit
yeah $44.99 seems kind of a little steep
I feel like but I don't know there could
be a lot of a lot of like like I said
there's 400 races you can have more
player competition on one screen
but I don't know it's kind of like that
argument to where it's like do you want
to pay $60 for you know adieu Mon switch
or Skyrim on switch
I mean portability is pretty big
obviously but I still think $60 for
those games is kind of a little steep
personally if yeah I know they can get
you know they can probably charge that
know that they'll be fine
I guess you'd say this is $40 this is 45
yeah I think so Steve
I think this but you know I haven't
played enough of it but so far all right
yeah you know gives you all these
dopamine hits with just all the stars
and the money and we have a lot of cars
yet or no position see there's a first
one way on the car I paid I think I paid
40 K for this so it hasn't occurred to
me to browse around the other shops yet
because yeah and it seems like you get a
lot of money too right from the from
doing these right races it was like
15,000 for your last one so and you do a
whole bunch of challenges twelve stars
classy fine asking is there an online
component no no okay later Matt a Colt
thanks for stopping by appreciate it
trying to read the chat as best as I can
see there's some questions and some
opinions some people saying this looks
very mobile
like we said there was gear Club and
that was an Android Android game so and
as Miguel said this does kind of give
them that mobile porch esque I mean
obviously it's better than what it would
be on mobile but I don't know and you're
driving the droid cons right now right
now we're not a problem okay nice I like
how you're up don't be drunk driver
interestingly enough I thought I was
gonna be put back into the map but
instead I am the game after finishing
the last race the game threw me into
this okay have you played handheld at
all out of curiosity or did you only
play docked
I played doc okay just curious what that
looks like versus docked maybe it looks
a little sharper handheld some people
saying tormentor DJing mobile racing
games look babe way better than this you
think so I guess well it's a smaller
screen right I guess yeah but could you
do four player competition I don't think
so
then djenka had to go there at least it
doesn't have Lube boxes I think
- yeah with the Super Mario here I think
this could have been more like a thirty
dollar game and 45 is it pretty tough
yeah it's like that weird in-between
like why like either go full 60 or just
go 30 I'm reminded of I think what the
first racing game that came out on Vita
was a mobile port by ubisoft asphalt
something-something oh yeah somebody was
talking about that it uh where was it
somebody YouTube chat had just mentioned
that actually shad got him this needs to
be an Android game technically gear Club
was an Android game this is gear club um
limited though John Doe thinks his game
should be $40 I'm kind of with that I
think thirty would have been a nice a
nice little price point there if I had
to choose yeah a lot of people just
basically savings to the mobile game Oh
Tobias thinks this looks worse than
asphalt on mobile hmm
yeah I heard you say it could be AI we
don't have we haven't played handhelds
so it's hard for me to say how much
better that that potentially looks but
uh congratulations thank you we reach
level five Miguel you got thirty seven
thousand I think we we do one more race
and you probably be able to oh you can
decorative furniture is that for like
just dressing up your garage oh you got
a garage yeah oh man alright does this
game have rain haven't seen any rain
okay no no environmental yeah that's a
good question though someone who
reviewed the latest Schwartz epic milk L
be saying I could actually jump buy this
for twenty dollars
oh is this uh was this maybe wait hold
on I'm so there might be online
correction I'm sorry there might
actually be oh okay correction there
might be we'll see we'll see there might
actually be online guys which would then
kind of make it I could see why it could
be a little bit more expensive now a lot
of people not digging the looks you know
hey it's part of the reason why Peter I
think wanted us to stream this and talk
about it is just to show it so you guys
can have a glimpse of what the game
looked like what looks like and just
quick impressions from ago Oh was that
nothing that League thing was that yeah
I hooked you up to Internet oh thank you
yeah pretty sure we're hooked up we
should check that out if it's a
possibility
Louella races that'd be fun oh that
could be cool yeah like that there's
difference in racing styles hopefully I
don't know how that's gonna drive but
let's try to check out the leagues real
quick and then we'll check out some
rally racing get on that dirt
Peter was like given gear club unlimited
it's what they deserved and I mean
normally I would just be doing destiny
so it's roughly about the same I feel
like all right we're gonna try go to
league here
not sure if we're gonna find any other
opponents I'd be interested to see
Tiffany are saying the gameplay looks a
little bit boring and I doesn't even
look like it's doing anything the
driving mechanics looks like gas and
turn
thanks for screaming the public service
to notice no problem that's part of the
reason why yeah
have you tried expert yet we'll try
expert next next race I'm curious how
much that affects anything in terms of
like the a eyes oh there they are
PR boss Dan Katz amumu oh dude this is
where we got to be at Miguel seems like
here's some real competition baby do you
think these are like real people or do
you think it's like one of those like
drive a taro type situations I think you
know it has to be a route whoa that was
it goes okay well I'm gonna go with like
it's like a drive Atari some punctuation
it's all right look at how much harder
it is already with other people and
you're not even colliding into them so
yeah do you agree is probably like a
driver tower type situation because I
mean you're ghosting through them like
that's weird to me unless I can't handle
it I think their driver cars I don't
know maybe someone in chat knows or
maybe I can look it up let me see
let's look at the game info oh yeah see
it's like challenge your friends
competing among up to four players on
the same screen as we mentioned or beat
their times online so yeah it's just a
time attack or it could be
[Music]
so it's like asynchronous multiplayer
unless that guy that's not the wording
that they use there but I won't you can
I don't know what that guys doing oh did
you already win the race okay you got
fit
so that's your time now so yeah it's
probably presumable that uh you know
that it's probably like your whoa all
right global ranking want to try that
again
why we want your global ranking sure I
think you can wealth in the world yeah
baby
day one that's when you got to break
records is day one hmm yeah Jesse
McCowan saying probably time attacks
like race Real Racing 3
all right okay I like the music though
yeah I tend to like the like car game
music yeah well there were some
chill-out tracks that I think that was
the first thing that made me alright
let's go test drive unlimited Joe we're
gonna win this race how do you see that
if you read if you can retain you'll get
like 14 championship Cup thing points or
something you know timed asynchronous
multiplayer events postman goddamn it
Chris to destiny to obviously PC iron
banners out this week I'm gonna have to
re-record my whole video clip because it
had no audio I think I'll double-check
when I'm almost positive we had no audio
to start this stream earlier than yeah
you can't live stream it I make a live
stream it later it's just easier just do
it on a VOD probably
let's try that again
[Music]
we're saying a whole bunch of ghosts yep
feetoes goes
also it is after the fact that we just
finished our extra life charity donation
I believe the page is still up so if you
want to donate for the kids that's still
there we didn't hit our goal of 15,000
but obviously the more money that's
donated the more the kids will benefit
obviously don't don't quote me on this
one but we might still have some
giveaways left oh yes
everything from a couple niche titles
like cat quest to an actual Xbox one
s well come on Miguel don't do worse
than last time
no pressure
oh that guy spun out or something well
he stopped at the same place either the
last time so he didn't tax so you did
get the fifth again
let's just go go do some rally reasons
you beat your time by like a second man
oh do we move up nope we're still in the
same spot aim you PR boss and Babbie
yeah all right that car looks nice
little Porsche I think all right you
want to do the rally or do you want to
do some alley all right
I wonder if this game follows that
recent trend or do you have to unlock it
you've nearly unlocked complete either
high village or back to the bay
championship all right where is that is
that the goal to your left a one will to
your left team coast did they say hi
village yeah I said [ __ ] I don't know it
said hi villager back to the bay can you
get back to the bay that one son I'm
almost done with - oh okay
well there you go all right wait did you
just go to top of the town I said I
don't need to know I think you did I
think I'm at high village I think you're
at top of the town it looks like a
mobile game lol looks like a mobile game
yes we've established that it looks a
little bit like a mobile port which is
not shocking because gear Club was a
mobile game but this is gear Club
unlimited on the switch out today for
$44.99
400 challenging racists and the ability
to play four player competitively on one
screen whoa nailed it
no problem
this is the most urban map so far
saved it
oh yeah we need a bump up I don't know
let's see if you have the ability later
to change it to expert I just want to
see if it how much harder it gets I
guess no no just keep going okay
don't stop now no no point doing it mid
match or did you want to try to figure I
think of human match like hey I'm in
first oh you can difficulty go up yeah
make it hard alright games on hard now
in 321
it's like we enhance the drivers all of
a sudden we're like hey you're all
better now you're all better now
all right we didn't make them good
enough for here at top of the town so I
guess you're in high village
championships I still the same thing we
can get a new part I think the biggest
giveaway that this is a mobile port is
the fact you're doing these races in one
lap it's two laps yes you have a couple
races in the yeah I mean here we're
playing it for your benefit you'll know
if you want to spend the 44 at 99 or not
I'm gonna say I wouldn't personally but
hey you never know what oh it's a
championship so we're doing yeah
yes we are doing this for your benefit
if tey didn't ask for volunteers for
this live stream I'm definitely be
playing something else right now yeah I
mean you even offered at like I think a
Ben Janko is something like yeah
probably fun I should get that I was
going to do that yesterday actually but
we saw it extra life so can we do that
tomorrow
battleship for good potentially or we
can always just record something in here
do it that way
but yes thank you guys all for tuning in
to watch us play or watch Miguel play
gear club unlimited as I talk to you
guys yeah fine I guess I don't know I
think the $44.99 is kind of steep for
what this is so far from what I've seen
well I am curious to see what the rally
stuff looks like if that's any different
for you or if that changes anything for
you but I'm gonna guess not too much you
know give a big Thanksgiving like plans
I'm not really just typical dinners with
family I'd do a little turkey football
or we call it turkey Bowl what do you
think Steven we usually get together and
put some flag football in the morning
you know like try to try to get your
exercise before you start eating like it
just amounts mountains of to you know
feel a little bit less bad about myself
you're so good against hard AI I guess
the only thing so far that it has been
like difficult or at least proved to be
a little difficult as a league stuff
yeah but at least it's I think it's just
a different mindset probably for you
like seeing them and like they're
probably running different lines with
not very difficult which is unfortunate
because even on the hardest difficulty
at least bull we are early in the game I
don't know if the game ramps up or not
but that the AI currently is indicative
of like what the AI is gonna look like
down the road it's kind of like we're
just gonna smoke up every time I guess
like that's like a four second gap
almost three seconds gap yeah maybe I'll
turn off a couple more I feel sorry for
you guys having to play hey you know
sometimes we gotta explore we're game
spot we explore multiple games not
always you know it's not always gonna be
queen with a crop you know and you never
know sometimes some of these smaller
games like turn out to be you know
potential gems you know and you guys
might not have known about it yeah like
I didn't know about a battleship Brigade
and that seems like an interesting game
just like conceptually because it's like
so many different things that in one
game kind of like a beat them up with
like puzzle you're cooking it's seamless
from the puzzle yeah I don't actually
think tiny medals out today coops you
right I think according to Peter it got
delayed till I think December I'll
double-check that for you though yeah
it's releasing December 21st
it's a month from now if you're curious
about tiny metal I know Peter is all
about it was that the advance wars
inspired game yeah yeah the tanks and
yes goob Tony lied to you I told him to
fix it already
Christian Laura asking games wat is this
game hampered by the lack of analog
triggers hello it about you mean control
wise
and felony issues okay
Oh according to Peter Brown there's big
controversy surrounding tiny metal I did
see that like really briefly yeah so
tiny so this is thirty two minutes ago
tiny metal delayed as accusations of
Kickstarter fraud swirled around the
developer that is the current state of
where that's at and I'm not going to go
on because we have news that does that
so there you go thank you're curious you
can look that up
- do you feel any difference here in
this I mean like other than the
environment - looking different roads a
little slippery
oh nice okay at least there's that so
there was like a performing shop I
noticed is that where you would tune
your car a little bit yes okay more like
upgrading parts yeah just making them
better I want a new car after this game
okay go oh this is uh this is this one
lap with that one laughs don't yeah I
think that was one that there was no
laps there so yeah you were right not
all of them - ups yeah a power slide
says rampage rel gear club for Gaudi
watching a movie hmm
I know about that what's up nitro Joseph
how goes it
all right we're gonna try to invest into
a new car after you get done with this
race championship race
you know this is table you know this is
the authentic engine sound I don't know
I don't I've never been in a 370 I mean
I think I've been in at 350 like at
least not the newer ones yeah oh all
right no damage
the Ryan cars hanging it looks like a
ps2 mobile game as we mentioned earlier
and this is going to continue I feel
like it is mobile ports essentially or
it feels like a mobile port sorry rather
I shouldn't say that it actually is a
metaphor it just feels like one but it
is made by the same guy
I think the same company that made gear
Club that was on Android phone correct
publishers and micro eights the
developer is eating games let me double
check that I actually I CPU the fennec
cat I would say this is like a low six a
low six out of ten from early like that
is just Miguel's opinion if you were to
ask him if he had to do some type of a
review currently and obviously oops it's
not I don't believe it's an actual like
straight port how many races are in this
championship I fumbled on my word
and I suspect this game probably
continues the recent trend of Toyota
pulling out their production cars from
racing games think so we have the maybe
the wrong let's see is there off-road
vehicles not sure Marc Andre we're gonna
check out some new cars after we're
going to championship race here oh we're
you know I'll actually not place first
for the first time you think so well
you're not tip following the line Miguel
that's just a checkpoint
[Music]
you gotta take Emily don't let her have
their get the bronze yes yeah I seems
like polite though the Toyota pulled out
a 410 GT sport there are no production
models there are sort of like this ooh
feel like f1 yet the professional race
what do they really have that's an
actual Toyota is is I guess because but
that's Lexus but that's still
technically owned by Toyota yeah and I
know there were very few like a Solara
No
in a Camry no way sorry I'm in a Prius
no way
LOL to muhammad sings which a lot or
Muhammad Allah be sings which is dead on
arrival I think you are crazy sir
Alberto Aguilar there's on line in the
sense that like you're kind of competing
against other people's time and like
essential it was essentially like time
driver tars so it's kind of based off of
a time race I guess right that's right
wording yeah all right oh we are rich
let's go to the car dealer got enough
cash to buy yourself a Mustang go to the
dealer
dude we got almost 100k we got to be
able to buy something hot something hot
Miguel single Lotus lotus doesn't cost
that much doesn't I have no idea that
Lotus is like yeah see it's only 47 273k
for a Lotus so oh good we can afford
more than ours
okay are these all the cards we can buy
hope so
got BMW a Mustang or some type of Ford
another Mustang we don't want a Mustang
no z4 roadster yeah I've never been a
fan of the Z series the Z line I've been
all right oh here's a lotus
we could see 65,000 all right what are
our other options what's that is that
another Lotus looks like it yeah and we
got another z4 roadster that's not oh so
is the right side like painted versions
of the left side because you're right
we've got fancy version we don't need
fancy we just need actual performance
here so I don't know what do you want to
do you want to go Lotus lotus all right
boom okay test drove it but instead
we're just gonna buy it cuz we got we
just ballin out of control
ballin oh you could have tuned it are
you tuned it yes we should at least look
at it correct should at least take a
gander ballin
yeah Ravager alpha will be interesting
to see what the third parties do on
switch you know there's a lot of
interest
I think even don't quote me on this I
think Julio is saying something about
square wanting to do more stuff on the
switch as well maybe they should have
brought Secret of Mana yeah interact
what's that is that our trunk yeah yeah
all right so how do we actually tune it
okay nice so it has your your 370z in
there then I'll grab it
oh wow oh excuse me let me just drop my
car okay yep yep
oh okay we can upgrade your engine let's
do it all right we can upgrade again we
are yup we got the money why not right
we haven't been doing all these races
for nothing
oh you got to upgrade your workshop now
some interesting barriers that's to be
expected a little bit very typical
progression I feel like you know don't
want you to be like sensible Oh P before
he do some races even though you kind of
already ROP I guess where are the palm
trees you won that's a good question
let's should we a pimp our garage so
this
oh there's a rally workshop okay let's
see you're right it's one of the tabs
ooh Oh what are you putting in here
what is this second it cost us money
wait go back see that same menu cuz I
saw that the tree stings so it's in that
tab right below Rich's there you go
Oh indoor bicycle coffee machine a seat
what are you gonna put in there a
vending machine all right indoor bike
you want to stay safe it don't block a
car you gotta put it near the mechanic
the guy needs soda well it seems like I
said you know you're gonna make him walk
all the way over there to get a soda oh
wait no you didn't drop it down way to
drop it oh my god I cannot believe
you're making your mechanic walk that
far when he's thirsty ever so thirsty
all right where we gonna put the indoor
bike yeah get to working out
all right that was the garage we tuned
our car a little bit got a new car we
got a lotus got to go back and earn some
new money so we can do some upgrades I
think there are some level barriers too
I think there's some stuff you can
unlock at 7:00 so what do we worry or do
you want to head to now let's do the
countryside tour all right we're gonna
tour the countryside ooh
going up against some nicer cars here
but we got a nice one too we got a nice
one too ding chatter
yeah thank you guys again for tuning in
we are playing gear come okay
your club I'm limited as it says on the
screen the game is out today for 4495 it
does have an online component you can
you know it's like time racing against
other people on the Internet you can
also play up to four players on the same
screen
is there another view I'm just curious
driving view not that there's not like a
button for you to change the view there
might well we're gonna find out that's
great
oh yeah all right I want you to drive
like this the rest of the time okay good
luck to you sir I like driving the other
way so do i I don't like this real life
stuff but you know we got to show off
you know different different sounds do
you think there's like a okay after this
we'll try to see if there's like the
third variant where it's like the
farther away cockpit I thought we were
in cockpit no we're hanging off the foot
oh we're hanging off the hood okay then
we'll do [ __ ] we'll see if there's
cockpit and then we'll see if there's
that really far kind of like you know
I'm talking about like where you're even
farther like you know Mario Kart you get
wide and it shows you like a bigger fov
almost sir
the fov that might be the wrong turkeys
but nice train Jakarta
step up Susan Wow
you're so good at crap talking while
racing
that turn is oh no yeah that's a good
one yeah that last time you got yet but
let's say you have adapted
this car sounds nicer though
if it's not authentic at least seem like
they put effort try to make your engine
sound good yeah
and I have no idea if this is what it
sounds like but
so good so good
so X is the rewind where if you didn't
like that turn you would essentially
just like have to like rewind you could
rewind back I can rewind all right
[Music]
didn't like that turn so let's start
like right here grope over put it yeah
let's let's start like right here yeah
BAM
didn't like that turn I made just like
in real life I can rewind time and take
that turn in all over again being same
result it's like you're at least
consistent Miguel thanks hey yeah
consistency is still key
yep cool all right we'll see if there's
another huh Miguel doesn't have friends
he has family thanks to Pineda oh we are
in a race what you don't understand is
how bad the AI is even though they're on
harm all right we're gonna OH nice level
seven I think you can actually upgrade
your workshop but we do that later this
is we were just in there hmm
level two tires
we're gonna see if there's another
racing view in the next race cuz this is
a championship right or was this just
one race I've been keeping I have not
been keeping track okay pretty good
stuff that's actually pretty funny
Christian I don't know about that but I
almost spent money you did almost damn
there you go Christian alright is there
another view or is it just so soon fair
enough
at least there was a second view we go
how was it racing like this was it was
it easier for you the other way it is we
did one whole race this way but if you
want to do it this way that's fine
maybe I'll get the AI chance
Wow
pretty sure they need it though
yeah so just in terms of people talking
about game of the year of our best of or
game of the year will start soon it's
gonna be I think in two weeks we're
gonna do live streams for like four
eight days in a row
not counting the weekends we're gonna
count down our best of ten for the year
we're gonna do ten to one but on the
last day we're gonna do three to one so
each day we're gonna reveal to you guys
our list or that game for like that spot
so like number ten will be on its own
for that day we'll discuss it will
probably play it a little bit and then
the next day we'll do number nine and
then the next day and over eight so it's
worth it so on we are gonna start kind
of for us internally here breaking that
down
come next week this is our last chance
weekend because Thanksgiving weekend
Liberation's play those games
yeah they'll be interesting to see you
know obviously everyone has their
personals and those will all be taken in
town and accounted for taking it into
account and we'll see where we land I
think three to one is gonna be the
hardest part though Oh actually and like
ten by ten it's gonna be a lot of
fighting for trying to get those games
in there so I like liberation so I could
I could play with my cell rate the RPMs
play with my rpms during this all right
Joe there's a roundabout that you have
to worry about we go he's telling you to
be careful
maybe Miguel is just to go hey
well yeah if you saw the live stream or
a [ __ ] against naked Claude oh yeah I
had fun playing nicking Claude - I could
do that every day Mick I get a Mikkel
against Nick
that is a I enjoyed every time I play
him because of just how come at he gets
I really I really was close to getting
him to smash his control I feel like I
almost beat him
one-eyed sunglasses one-handed and
almost beat him it was to - who said oh
man this is a tougher one for you I
should have listened to Joe something
about a roundabout I don't think you've
gotten it though right well this is a
whiny er than usual all right that's
good some diversity that's weird that
you just phase through that car but you
hit certain other cars or how do you hit
any of the car sir suggests you running
into it just goes in this that's weird
did you hit any cars earlier I thought
you did I did oh okay
okay that's really weird oh here's the
roundabout points it out here's the road
map Oh Joe told you to be careful Miguel
that's kind of cool I like that
like hey gets it it's like a real eight
like like a little race not real a race
but like a race you get to the end and
have to go back to the beginning
suck it Brittany we're coming for you at
first I thought it might be a Skyline
GTR but I don't think it was did those
cars just morph in front of you so
apparently for some reason in this race
were like ghosting through them like we
would during one of those league time
race type things earlier we were running
into cars so it is kind of weird that
we're just go stting through them in
this one because we're not I know like
League race right now where it's like a
Time Attack oh [ __ ] it's weird though
because this is on isn't a Time Trial
right dammit Brittany yeah and David
oh wait I see
oh you got second third oh no one crash
okay so at least hard the hard guys are
a little bit more difficult marc-andre
it's really not fun all right there's
Miguel's opinion seems like kind of just
me I'm looking forward to spending more
time with divinity this week for doing
my part in the game of the Year
deliberations we're trying to find the
good in this game just McKay Macallan my
guy was not having that much fun playing
I pretty much you don't see it but
there's a like shackle down there and he
has two on his leg and he has to finish
playing this for like another 10-15
minutes the most fun I've had so far as
modifying our garage putting our vending
machine in putting our stationary bike
in
[Music]
but yeah I think it's fine I just think
that oh here now we're running into
people it's fine I just think the price
points a little high personally I think
if you said hey this game is $20 you
could get some people to kind of you
know play it because this is one of the
first like actual car racing games on
the switch you know you know very
surprised ends flare I was very
surprised how oh that's the first time
we got air sorry get you out there go
ahead there isn't I think every headline
I'm seeing for this is like it's the
first like a real racing game so in fact
I lost my damn clue Museum
do you know if the joint like if you're
able to play the game with just one
boycott why not right
someone was asking about the competitive
or the the split-screen maybe well
considering that there is four players
foot screen
yeah I like that you should be able to
do it with your time I mean you could do
it in rocket League so is there a
cockpit view no this there's only two
views there's like the kind of like on
the hood holding onto the hood as we go
would save you and then that kind of
like their car view third person car
view third car view
so you're saying waiting for the sequel
yep sure AM we'll see you next time on
gear Club and limited to where it gets
more unlimited salad
I play this game on my phone there is a
mobile version called gear club on
Android I'm not sure if it's on iOS I
definitely saw it on Android
rhyme it up trying to incite some anger
from the chat I don't think you have to
though because I think a lot of people
would agree with your statement it is
also on iOS as after people thank you
yeah I don't know so like I I'd have to
play the mobile version but like I
wonder if like you're just better off if
you're gonna want that on the go just
playing that instead of paying $45 for
this yeah I just complimented you know
ran into the wall I enjoyed that
you know let's show them the rewind
rewind that you're gonna do that turn
better see so you can do this in the
game if you guys didn't know right here
yep yeah you might as well take it from
see that's kind of cool if I messed you
up more Oh nailed it boom
[Music]
did it yeah yeah it felt good for me too
and ballin that's right tip inator we
ballin oh good save good save good save
[Music]
that's right I mean I wish the game
could reward you for like not hitting
anything like passing or drafting
there's not even a you're getting
rewarded right now through stars baby
this is uh this is a championship right
like we've been in this thing yeah but I
don't like a traditional championship or
like the opponents like get points and
have a chance to win the championship
yeah we're gonna finish out this race
and then maybe go back into the garage
and we're probably all the same because
I don't I don't know how much more of a
second and we started late we started
like 10 minutes late so I'm sorry to
everyone that we started late that was
my fault I've had 22 technical
difficulties I I still got to fix this
PC there's something wrong with it oh
[ __ ]
you know what rewind it you gotta use
that functionality Miguel
yep aka retry this is basically like
retry
ah wiser they're wiser
well that's all race I mean with a
success in racing games is is knowing
your track
it's actually interesting that they give
you the line every time probably okay
all right that's that's that's cuz
usually they kind of start showing you
that a little bit but then they don't
later on right or do they they don't
usually show you like the line the whole
time today in like TTE or manually turn
it off
Oh shows you how long it's been since
I've played a racing game I think the
last like legitimate racing game I
played was like Ridge Racer on ps2
like one of the road racers that's right
come at me yeah there's some there's
some racing purists I'll give you a lot
of crap why we've been doing the same
map oh that would have been some burnout
moment right there a lot of people do
it's like what I like the top requested
like is in our backwards compatibility
yet because isn't that like one of like
the highest voted ones that's a good
question no chat do you guys know I know
that is one of the
we can try split-screen - I don't know
if it'll work off one joke on but we can
give it a go in a second - that's a good
point all of you remember I remember oh
oh look at you look at you the
perfectionist is coming out this is like
up head when you're just like no we try
lots of lost health or Eddie must get
perfect run I need to watch Joey's
they're pretty good
[Music]
[Music]
nice very nice please be the end of
countries of the Tour Championship
countryside Tour Championship please or
do you have to three star everything
without why because it's like you did
this it clearly says you've done this
let's just go to the map let's just go
to the map I don't care yes
okay let's try coat like a one-on-one
split-screen I guess we'll see if it
works with the just one side of joy I
have to back out of the map all right we
go back out of the map
this looks pretty big though oh we gonna
OH new zone car dealer how can we go
check out the yeah
is that him for oh man and for I'd do it
for them for oh and there's a yeah yeah
unless there's a Viper
it's the only Dodge car things cool
thanks we're not paradise is backwards
compatible thank you I see five four
three four that who watch them spin skip
it that Bentley or is it that uh yeah it
isn't Bentley
especially I don't tell you when you
highlight like that now they want you to
get the scat pack challenger hopefully
m4 m4 coupe okay how much was that I
want your oh my god 150 we can't afford
that
okay that's like the trick that trick
that's why the trick that we're gonna
Lotus where's the game won't like to use
real money that's a good thing Miguel
damn it
well it's a good thing yes but I can be
cynical alright here we go
we're gonna try to do the split screen
hopefully we can do it off one set of
joy Khan's if not we'll probably just
end it there but we'll see maybe I can
take Miguel maybe I can hit the pause
button while we're racing like dammit
Miguel you cheater restart
bring back blurr please says honor on
veut Anirban Co math Majumdar don't give
them any ideas Miguel see I agree Raisa
four players Hey you got in trouble man
you got in trouble Peter says no review
score type talk during these streams
it's fine
no that's fine like I fixed it for you
right away when you said that I was like
that's what you feel like in this moment
we're good that's not the actual review
for the game it's just what Miguel feels
in the moment opinion yeah anyways does
this work two players are supported
press L and ru you do that first
here
yes we know all these things aren't you
already sink though it says two players
are supported but you're good
does that not work yeah but should one
of the joy cons be so that's Illinois
that is stupid please connect enough
controllers do you need both probably
dammit I guess that kind of makes sense
okay I guess you can't play on one side
of joy Klein's unless I'm crazy it won't
let you until you connect another
controller okay yeah
Zr and L are not Ln R I think we tried
that you tried that too right yeah I'm
pretty sure you need another another
controller okay yeah we did that well
all right well thank you guys so much
for watching a me Miguel play gear club
unlimited we appreciate you guys hanging
out
don't forget wow this was off the whole
time how did I do that Miguel look at
this picture in picture this whole time
I got slid I mean you only fixed that
OOP sorry you guys should have told me
that sooner anyways thank you guys for
watching we think it's very just okay at
best probably I'm suppose wasn't a
launch game do you feel like it's just
okay or just okay just okay 4495 it is
out today Thank You Miguel for playing
the role feel free shoot it and thank
you guys all for tuning in until next
time have yourselves a wonderful
Thanksgiving week we'll be back tomorrow
with the lobby at 11 a.m. so if you guys
have seen that before it's our weekly
talk show essentially gaming talk show
with Mike Peter Callie and Rob come back
tomorrow until next time guys thank you
so much later later